Brett Kavanagh has been I'm sure you've
heard by now Brett Kavanagh has been
accused of sexual assault or attempted
sexual assault when he was 17 over three
decades ago and the Democrats became
aware of this accusation months ago but
have only coincidentally decided to come
forward with it now while well right
before the confirmation is supposed to
be go through so they they you know just
coincidentally they decided at the very
last minute to say oh hey by the way
here's this thing now we'll get to the
Democrats role in all this in a second
but let's first take a look at the
allegation itself I'll read this is the
allegation as reported by Fox News it
says the woman Christine Ford is a
professor at Palo Alto University
according to Washington Post which
published her account on Sunday looking
for the actual accusation afford a 51
year old registered Democrat who was
published in academic journals and
trained students in clinical psychology
described the alleged incident on Sunday
saying it occurred at a Maryland teenage
house gathering Ford claimed she headed
upstairs to a bathroom when she was
suddenly pushed onto a bed as rock and
roll music Blair how ever Ford told the
post she did not recall exactly who
owned the house how she came to be at
the house or how the gathering was
arranged she remembered only that the
house was in Montgomery County near near
a country club and the parents and their
parents were not present Ford said she
remembered that during one summer in the
early 1980s Cavanaugh and a friend mark
judge or stumbling drunk and laughing
maniacally those are both quotes when
Cavanaugh pinned her to a bed and tried
to forcibly remove her one-piece bathing
suit as well as the clothes she was
wearing according to Ford Cavanaugh put
his hand over her mouth when she
attempted to scream I thought he might
inadvertently kill me said Ford who
works as a research psychologist in
California he was trying to attack me
and remove my clothing for claims she
was able to escape to a bathroom and
then outside of the house when judge
mark judge the other guy allegedly
involved jumped jumped into the fray and
sent everyone in the room quote tumbling
[Music]
okay now we are we're told that Ford the
accuser she told this story to a
therapist in 2012 and the notes of that
therapy session have been were given to
the Washington Post and she also passed
an FBI lie-detector test and a lot of
people are making a big deal out of that
that she passed a lie-detector test now
I don't you know the fact that she told
this to a therapist is potentially
significant we'll get that get to that
in a second the fact that she passed a
lie-detector test doesn't tell you
anything because number one lie-detector
tests are junk science you know the way
people talk about lie-detector tests
polygraph tests it's as if people really
think that it's literally a lie-detector
test like it can read your mind and if
you tell a lie it says well that was a
lie but that's of course not how it goes
it reads certain body signals certain
things that are going on with you
physically and then the person
administering the test interprets that
as being you know a sign of anxiety or
nervousness which is then interpreted as
being a sign that you told a lie so
there it's just there's a lot of
interpreting going on and as I said it's
junk science because here's the thing
about a lie detector test ironically if
you're really good at lying and you lie
all the time if you're a pathological
liar if you tell a lot of lies all the
time
then you'll probably pass a lie-detector
test but if you're very honest and
scrupulous there's a very good chance
that you'll fail the test
um so that's why you can't you can't
take the stuff seriously
but she did okay so she told someone in
2012 that is a you know a new piece of
information that is potentially
significant because that would seem to
alleviate the concern that she just
concocted this whole story now out of
the blue
although
she didn't apparently name Cavanaugh in
2012 and her story has changed she said
at 2012 that it was for guys who were
involved now she says it's two that's a
significant change that's we've just cut
in half the number of attempted rapist
which is significant I mean that that
proves that that would seem to indicate
that there is a certain degree of
unreliability in the story that we're
being told which doesn't necessarily
mean that she's lying it could mean that
she just really doesn't know exactly
what happened okay so let me make a
let me back up for a minute I'll just
make a few general points about all this
and just give you my perspective on it
number one going back to the Democrats I
want to be clear on one thing that the
Democrats are truly evil I mean they are
despicable wicked disgusting satanic
evil I mean I mean what we know about
this no matter who's lying who isn't
lying no matter what happened no matter
what happened 35 years ago here's what
we know for sure that the Democrats
involved here are scumbags
we know that the Democrats are scumbags
whether Cavanaugh is a liar whether
Christine Ford's liar whether the but
you know whatever else we certainly know
that the Democrat politicians involved
with putting this allegation other they
are scumbags because they were contacted
with the story months ago but they held
it they saved it until right before the
confirmation so that they could cause
maximum panic and prevent Republicans
from confirming someone else so what
they were concerned with you know they
don't care about women they don't care
about this woman they don't care about
women in general this is a transparent
ploy on their part they are using this
cynically and blatantly for their own
benefit and they're they're scumbags
either way because either they think
that this allegation is not credible in
which case they're scumbags for coming
forward with it or they think it is
credible in which case they're scumbags
for holding on to it all this time so
they're scumbags either way we know that
number two
when we first heard this story out of
nowhere on Friday I said that the
allegations deserve to be dismissed out
of hand if no additional evidence is
provided for them well since then we
found out about the polygraph we found
out about the therapists thing now I
don't know if we would call that that's
not really evidence okay that's not
evidence against Brett Kavanaugh
evidence would be like a an eyewitness
that can corroborate her testimony but
the only other eyewitness mark judge has
already denied this so now it's two
against one so I don't know if we could
say that there's any evidence on her
side however the fact that she told this
story or a version of its you know
several years ago before Brett Kavanaugh
was you know in the running for the
Supreme Court that would seem to
indicate that she probably isn't lying
about the whole thing she may be even
telling the truth the entire truth as
she sees it that does not however mean
that it happened exactly as she's
telling maybe it did
maybe it didn't but she's foggy on the
details and it happened a long time ago
she doesn't remember when it happened
she doesn't remember where it happened
she doesn't remember how she ended up
where she was so we have been given a
very cloudy snapshot of an event that
occurred somewhere in Montgomery County
sometime in the early 80s I mean that
means we can't really say that this
happened exactly as she said because she
doesn't even know exactly how it
happened or who was involved
even if she's not being dishonest so we
don't even need to get into you know
accusing her of lying accusing Kavanaugh
of lying
given the fact that this happened 35
years ago allegedly and that's she's so
cloudy about the details there's just a
lot of there's a lot that isn't known
Third Point even some supporters of
Cavanaugh are saying that well look if
this is true then he lied about it and
lying is a very serious thing especially
if he wants to be a Supreme Court
justice and if he lied to the FBI during
all those background checks that he's
taken throughout his career then you
know then that's reason enough I mean he
even their argument is yeah this
happened three and a half decades ago
but the lying is much more recent
and I agree by the way that if this did
happen and if he has been lying about it
all this time then that is disqualifying
clearly but hold on a second she says
herself that Brett Kavanaugh was
stumbling drunk those are her words so
isn't it possible even isn't it even
quite likely that if it did happen he
really doesn't remember this thing that
happened when he was extremely
inebriated as a teenager 35 years ago
isn't that very possible isn't it
possible that for 35 years this has all
been to him a non memory or at best a
very hazy you know recollection of
something happening at a party when he
was drunk I mean III think in order to
call Cavanaugh a liar you have to assume
a that it happened and be that he
remembers it happening exactly as Ford
says that it happened and I think both
of those assumptions especially the
second are dubious at best
number four going back to the vagueness
of these allegations remember that um
she is unsure of some of the fundamental
details like when and where so she
doesn't know when and where but she
knows who well she doesn't even know
exactly who because she said four before
now she says - so that's that that's
that's a problem and also there are
other details here that she you know how
do we know that she's clear about some
of the other details details like
she says that she was shoved into the
bedroom she says that Cavanaugh put his
hand over her mouth
so in order to
hold this against Cavanaugh
that all this happened he remembers that
it happened he's been lying about it
and we also have to assume that she is
absolutely 100% sure about those few
details there but she's not miss
remembering them or she's not
exaggerating them or inventing them I
mean all these different possibilities
because hypothetically if this
if some sort of incident did happen but
she wasn't shoved into the bedroom let's
say she went into the bedroom willingly
with two drunk guys and the hand over
the mouth thing never happened but if
you remove those two things from the
situation it starts to color everything
a little bit differently so the point is
with something like this every last
detail is so important yet we have a lot
of we have very we have many very good
reasons to doubt
the details that we've been given also
another point
I mean I've
I don't know if anyone's asked her this
yet but was she herself drunk at this
party because she was at a house party
with other teenagers the others were
plastered according to her so was she
stone-cold sober or was she also drunk
cuz if she was then that would obviously
hinder her ability to remember what
actually happened fifth thing a 5th
point I want to make okay let's assume
let's assume for a minute that this did
happen it did happen like she said it
happened let's assume that no I don't
think we can't assume that because as I
said we've got a we'd have to we have to
leap over some other very real
possibilities
that she's lying that she's
misremembering that they're you know
that there's some combination of truth
and fiction and we'd have to skip over
all of those to land on the assumption
that it actually happened I don't think
we can do that but let's for a second
let's say that we do do that let's say
that we assume that it did happen then
we're left with another question I think
it's an important question and that is
should a man be denied a position
because of a bad thing that he did while
he was drunk as a high school or 35
years ago
I it seems like there are a lot of
people who are 100% sure that well yeah
of course I don't think it's so obvious
now if it did happen then it's a really
bad thing this is not like knocking over
mailboxes or egging somebody's house or
even shoplifting a pack of gum from CVS
but
assuming that this is not part of a
pattern of behavior assuming that he
hasn't continued doing these things if
he did do it at all and there hasn't
been any other women that have come
forward to accuse him in fact there have
been 65 women that came forward to
attest to his to his his character so
assuming that it was you know that
that's not part of a pattern then we
have to ask ourselves what should we do
with the bad behavior of a 17 year old
guy 35 years ago
this is where I know a lot of you will
disagree but I you know I give a fair
amount of leeway to people for
indiscretions even really bad
indiscretions from their teenage years I
just have trouble with the idea that a
person's life and career should be
destroyed because of the worst thing
they did as a drunken kid decades ago
and I also think that the vast majority
of people setting that standard and
defending it now would not be happy if
it was applied to them listen I'm not
saying that most people have sexual
assaults in their background or
attempted assaults I'm not saying that
this kind of thing is quote normal for
for teenagers but um you know there are
a lot of really bad things that
teenagers can do to each other a lot of
different ways they can abuse each other
and so there are a lot of people who
have
bad things from their teenage years in
their past even if it's nothing sexual
right so think about let's just take a
common example think about a guy who was
sixteen fifteen sixteen years old
whatever and he was a vicious bully
let's say he bullied let's say that he
was a there was one particular kid in
school who he tormented and he bullied
and even to the point of physically
assaulting him right now is that as bad
as what Kevin Cavanaugh allegedly did
yeah I mean maybe I mean it kind of
depends but that could be at least as
bad
and anyone who you know growing up was
ever tormented by someone else in school
to that extent you know that this I mean
this is the kind of thing clothes cause
lasting psychological you know but it's
like just a terrible person as a
teenager just awful and
let's say they grow up and so they've
spent like twice as long being a decent
person as they spent being a horrible
teenager or three you know even longer
than that should we then go and dig up
those skeletons decades later and use it
against them
that's the question
I'm I'm just I'm uncomfortable with that
because teenagers can be extremely
vicious selfish ruthless dishonest that
doesn't excuse the behavior
and that's not to say that all that all
bad behavior as a teenager is to the
same degree and is you know is it's not
all equal right but my point is that
it's perfectly plausible that a person
could be terrible as a teenager or just
be a terrible person and do terrible
things but then turn into a decent
honest adult that's perfectly plausible
it happens all the time
and if you understand the psychology of
teenagers and all the things are going
to it you know it's just they're there
again it's not an excuse it's just
putting things into a certain context
and then asking to what extent decades
later
should you be held to account for things
that that you did as a kid the
transition from teenagehood to adulthood
is a transition where a person can
really change transform significantly a
lot of people do most people do
hopefully so it's dip this is not the
same look this is not it's this is not
the same thing as saying that just
because something happened a long time
ago that automatically means that that
you are you know that you shouldn't be
held responsible for it now because you
know if
um
if you're 55 years old and you did
something terrible when you were 35
which is 20 years ago that's a long time
but you were 35 years old so you were a
grown adult at that point
or if you're 70 years old and you did
something when you were 60 or in your
50s yeah you could say well that was two
decades ago that was a decade ago yeah
but you were a grown person at that
point I mean you were completely totally
grown
so you could certainly argue now of
course people do people can have
transformations even as adults but most
of the time if you're a total scumbag at
35 then you're probably gonna be a
scumbag at 50 and if you were a scumbag
at 50 you're probably gonna be a scumbag
at 70 and and so on and so on because
now there are exceptions but in most
cases people's character and personality
kind of solidify at a certain point and
then that's just how they are
so that it's kind of rare that you would
you know you would know somebody when
they're 40 and they're a total scumbag
and then you don't seem to a while and
then you and then you meet him again at
60 and they're completely changed and
everything is different about them that
does happen it's rare
on the other hand it's very common that
you could know someone when they're 16
and then meet them again when they're 36
and say wow this is a totally different
person because it is a totally different
person a person's character and
personality has not set in has not
solidified at the age of 17 or 20 or
even 25 these days
so I just think you have to allow you
have to take that into consideration you
know you have to allow for that reality
while you're you know when you're when
you're analyzing these sorts of
situations
so that's all I mean when you when you
if you're looking at a guy now and then
you find out that 35 years ago when he
was a kid he did a really terrible thing
what bearing does that necessarily have
on who he is now
and remember that that if well here's
the sixth thing with all these things
considered I don't see how you could
take this nomination away from Brett
Kavanaugh and in fact not only should it
not be taken away unless something
changes like between now and I mean
unless there's some huge revelation
something significant change but as it
stands right now I don't see how you
could take this up this nomination away
from Kavanagh and in fact I think it'll
be a very very very dangerous precedent
if you did think about the precedent the
precedent is that a guy at the last
minute
can have an opportunity or position
taken away from him based on
unsubstantiated uncorroborated
accusations which are which which have
been vaguely transmitted from someone
who can't even remember all the details
you know accusations dating back to when
the person was a kid decades ago that to
me is a very dangerous precedent
and it's a precedent that a lot of the
people that are setting that precedent
if it were applied to them they would be
not happy
even if they don't have sexual assaults
or a quote you know alleged attempted
assaults in their background they have
things that they did when they were
teenagers that you know now that it's 20
years later 30 years later if it was
held against them or used as
justification to take an opportunity
from them they would think it was the
most unjust and unfair thing in the
world
I think that's the case for a lot of the
people who now want this precedent to be
set on the other hand if the
confirmation goes through what's the
precedent there
well the precedent is that you can't
come at the last minute with these
unsubstantiated allegations from decades
ago when the guy was a kid you know you
can't do that and that's and that's a
fine precedent that's a good precedent
that's what the precedent should be
so unless something changes unless
something really serious changes I think
you just have to go through push through
this
and if Republicans allow themselves to
be beaten back and they give up on
Kavanagh because of this because they're
scared away by it
I think that would be an enormous
enormous mistake
thanks for watching everybody thanks for
listening
Godspeed